こんにちは
科学をやっている人間がこういうあの
一般的な方の前でお話する時っていうのはだいたい定番っていうものがありまして
まあ面白そうな実験を見せするとかあるいはこう我々の身の回りにある非常に重要な
化学製品について話して
まあ親しみを持ってもらうなんてことがだいたい定番なんですけれども
先は
待っておきますちょっとそんな面白い話出てきません
越冬だからまああの楽しそうなスライドも出てこないし面白い実験を見せることもあり
ませんただ
よりちょっとこの方ね科学の本質に触れるような話をしていきたいというふうに思い
ます
で唯一あの綺麗なスライドはこれですもう見納めですからよく見ておいてください
どうですか綺麗な花ですよねこれ見て皆さんと思いますか
あ綺麗な肌だなぁと思ってまぁ写真撮りたいな絵を書きたいな
何か2で歌ってみようかないろいろ思うと思うんですけれども
各やっている私は科学者なりの好奇心があってこれを見ます
一体木の葉丼な元素でできてるのかなぁなんて思うんです
ねどうですか科学者って変ですよね
そうなんですね価格っていうのは元素を中心に物事を考えるというそういう学問なん
ですね
あのば経営学と書いているので何かものが変化するものを扱っていると思っていると
思うと多いと思うんですけどそれはもう品の一つの科学の側面です大事なのは元素を
中心に考えるということですね
これ私元素間
という風によく読んでいます
では皆さんこの元素っていくつあるかご存知ですか
これぐらいありますね
これちょっとあまり馴染みのない秋季ようですねこれ本当はこうなんですけど幅が広
すぎるのでだいたい皆さんちょっとこういう形で見ていると思います
なじみのある宗教になりました
元素っていうのは実は100個なんですねだいたい100個あります
この100という数字多いでしょうか少ないでしょうか
私はこれで非常に少ないと思いますよく考えてくださいね
このように入ったいくつのものがあるでしょうか
とんでもない数ありますよねそれが立った100個のパーツしからしかできていないと
思う
これはもう驚きとしか言いようがないと思います
そしてもう一つ重要なのはこの100個のパーツが全部それぞれ別々なんです
それぞれ別々の違った性質を持っているんですね
そしてこちらからこちらの元素を作り変えることもできないし
またこれとこれのちょうど間ぐらいの制す欲しいなぁと思ってもそんな作れないですね
とにかくこの100個からしか我々も作ることができない
これまず
意識しておいてください
人間は昔からまあものが一体どんなゲームをどういうものからできているのかという
ことを考えるのは非常に大きな興味の対象でした
例えばアリストテレスの時代というのは一空気と水と辻
そういうものから万物ができているというようなことをまあ考えていたわけですね
で時代がだんだんとこちらに来て
錬金術の時代になります
錬金術と聞くと皆さんなんかちょっと胡散臭い話だなぁと思うかもしれませんが違うん
ですねアルケミーっていうのは chemistry 科学の語源になっている非常に
重要な実は活動だったんです
錬金術は非金属から貴金属を作るまあ例えばあの異様とか水銀のような安物の元素から
キラキラ光り輝く価値のあるあの金を作るですまあそんな活動していたんですね
だんだんこう概念がいろいろほとんでしまって例えば不老不死に効くような魔法の石を
探す作る
賢者の石ですねそんなものを求めるなんていう活動にも発展していきました
でも皆さんご存知のように錬金術の活動というのはすべて目的としては
を達成することはできませんでしたただこの活動によってやはり元素というのは
もともと
ものが決まっていて新しい元素を作ることもできないし
作り変えることもできないという非常に基本的なことがここでわかったそれが
科学の発展科学の礎になったということは間違いないわけですね
では皆さん元素間という関連で我々の身の回りを見てみましょう
我々の身の回りにはどんな元素があるでしょうか
例えば地球例えば我々の体
どんなものでできているか考えてみましょう
実はこんなもでできていますねちょっと眺めてくださいどうですか
地球っていうのはどうですか酸素とケースを沢山ありますね要するに値表っていうのは
酸化ケイ素で覆われている実は我々そんな上で暮らしてるわけですね
一方我々の体はエッジ頭が多いですね水素と酸素まいち2お水の起用が多いのでこれ
多いです
ですから就学は第3番目のしーたんそうですね
だからざっくりいうと地球はケイ素でできていて我々は炭素でできています
どうですか
面白いですかどってことないですかどうでしょ
これ実は我々のように減速感があるとものすごく面白くこの分布表を見ることができ
ます
先ほどの周期表でターン外計測器の実は上下関係にあるんですね
これは仲間ということですよ
半ばであるにも関わらず我々の体はケイ素じゃなくて炭素使っていうんですね
変だと思いませんか始原的にパールケースを使えばもっと効率がいいはずですねターン
そて実は今だけしかないですよすごく非効率なこと我々しています
なんていうそんな興味が好奇心が出てくるわけです減速感があると
逆に言うとですよわざわざこの炭素を使っているんだからきっと何か秘密があるはずだ
な
そんな好奇心も元素感があると湧いてきます
じゃあちょっと炭素てどんなもんか考えてみましょうもう1回秋季を出しますこれ我々
があの中学校時代に親しんでいた短周期が他の周期表にちょっとあの変化させてみてい
ますさあ今主役のターン数をどこにありますか
ちょっと見つけて下さい
見つかりましたか
ここですね
真ん中の一番前センターフォワードです
ですかもう憧れの1ですよねだからタンスはすごいです
っていうのはそうですよでも半分冗談で半分本当です
この気丈に特別な位置にいるってことが炭素のまあ言ってみたら素晴らしさんですね
注記表の一番前一番上にいるって事は結合を作るときに実はいろんな角度で作れる柔軟
性があるということを意味します
それか周期表の真ん中にあるというのは例えば周期表のこちら側にある元素は電子を
あげたいなぁという性質が強いですね
こっちの元素は逆にもらいたいなと思っています真ん中にあるやつはあげるとかもらう
とかまぁどっちもできまあある意味中途半端なんですね
でも色々とれこれ科学的な用語で言うと
たような参加すう音
いるということになります
まとめて言うとこのセンターフォワードの炭素はいろんな形をつくっていろんな参加数
を取れるということを両方できる唯一無二の元素であるということが周期を元素感が
あるとわかってくるわけです
ちょっと面白くなってきましたか例を挙げましょういろんな形作れます例えば立体的な
もの平面的なもの
直線的なの3 d 2 d 1 d のユニットに炭素は簡単にあることができます
これでできる非常に単純な分子エタン1年アセチレンなんていうのは工業的に
ものすごく重要な原料ですね
これをずっとつなげたものはポリエチレンポリアセチレンと言って今皆さんの身の回り
にものすごくたくさん使われている
大切な大切な素材です
ノーベル賞を取っていることからもその重要性が皆さん推察できると思います
もう一方を見てみましょういろんな参加数を取れる a ですね
例えばタンパク質 bna 見たみーへ皆さん言葉は聞いたことあると思います
でも我々元素感があるのでどんな元素でできてるかなぁってすぐ見たくなるんですね
一番下に書いてるやつですどんな元素でできてるかっていう構造式ってやつですね
よく眺めてください炭素どこにありますか c ですね
いっぱいあります大活躍してますね形を形作るこの分子の形をつくっている
骨組みに全部使われています
それからこの図ではポンド王とか n とかいっぱいありますね
それとくっついているということはこれ実はいろいろな参加数を取れるということを
意味しています
ですからいろんな形を作れていろんな参加数を取れるからこそこんな大切な物質を作る
ことができて我々の体の中でものすごく働いているということです
ケイ素にはこういうことはできないです
もう一回見てみましょうかどうですかさっきと味方変わりましたよねちょっと幻想感が
出てきたので少し興味深くこの絵を見るようなことができるようになってきたんじゃ
ないでしょうか
ですから
減速感があるとそれなりの好奇心というものが湧いてきます
そうするとなんと我々は世界が違って見えるんですね
どうですか幻想感があると楽しいという風なイメージを分かっていただけるんじゃない
かと思います
でここで大事なのはまあ好奇心ということですね好奇心ってどういうものかということ
ちょっと別の角度から考えてみましょう
焚き火ストーブエアコンてありますねこれ共通て皆さんわかりでしょうか分かりますよ
ね
こう寒くなってきました後暖を取るものですね
でこの順番にぺクノロジーはずっと発展していっている
これは皆さんだいたい想像できると思います
例えば想像してくださいね焚き火カラス道具になった時代多分これはものすごく好奇心
をもって受け入れられたと思います
このストーブってどうやってこう上手く燃料を入れてこんなに安全にうまく日を
コントロールできるんだろう
すごくね喜ばれて好奇心でこの仕組みがどうなってるんだろうってみんな思ってみたと
思うんですね
ですからもうや今ですね今もか暖かく契約んから出てますけどこれもう不幸 pc は
爆発しているはずですよね
テクノロジーが発展していけるんでね
じゃあここで皆さんに一つの質問します皆さんエアコンからどうやって温かい空気出て
くるか説明できますか
どうでしょうか
この質問で私ちょいちょいいろんなところでするんですけれども実は理科系の学生さん
でもこれ案外満足に応えられないということがたくさんあるんですね
おかしな話ですねこうテクノロジーが発展していって好奇心がどんどん膨らんで言っ
てるならば
ねそんなことぐらい答えるはずなわけです逆に答えれないということは好奇心が爆発し
ているところが実は好奇心がすぼんで行っているという状況ですね
どういうことかというと最近の若い人たちは好奇心や興味が一切ない
まあしょうもない人たちがいっぱいできていると
いうことになるんですが
ねと言われても困りますよねえで胸し安心してください実はそういうせいじゃないです
ねこれはねこうならざるを得ない理由がありますそれを今から説明します
これ横軸が時間で縦軸が度合いです科学の発展というのはだいたいこういうふうに発展
していってますねはじめなかなか大変だけどもあるとききっかけを掴んでからグーッと
ご清聴する
たぶんこういう曲線になっている指数関数みたいになっているというかみなさん
イメージがつくと思うんですね
じゃあこれに対応して好奇心ってどうなっているでしょうか
例えば一つ仮定しますこの変化の割合ですね
方向きです難しくと尾部んですけどもそれに対応しているとするならば
指数関数の微分だから好奇心も指数関数で出るはずですね
でも多分私これはちょっと違うと思うんですね私の家庭です好奇心は多分微分じゃなく
て微分をその値で割ったらいいと思います
ちょっと話が英国祝なってきて申し訳ないですよ簡単にいますね例えば科学の発展が
まだあんまりない頃というのは傾きが小さいですね
また会も小さいので割り算したらそこそこの値になります
彼はがグーッと発展している時は傾きがすごく大きいけども値も大きいので割り算する
とそこそこの値ます
またになりますだから好奇心はラース曲線詫び文をそのその時の科学のど微分をその値
で割るとこの式であらわされると思います
ですから指数関数的に科学が発展してやっと好奇心はいっ
体に保たれますよということを表しているわけですね
でもちょっとこれは私がさっき言った話とずれてますよねさっき私は価格がどんどん
発展すると好奇心がすぼんでいきますよという話をしました
だってやこんなこと皆さん知らなかったですからね
なんででしょうか
もう一つファクターがあります
残念ですけれども理解の限界っていうのがあるんですね
もちろんそのあるものを扱っている科学者はこの科学の発展というものをしっかりと
理解していますけれども多くの人たちは彼に科学者であってもですね理解に限界がある
わけですよだからこの垢で赤で示した曲線でしか
科学の発展を感じることができないということがあると思うんですね
ですからこれに従ってあの好奇心曲線を取ってやると当然下がっていきます
ですからこれは何を意味しているかと言うとこれ怖い式ですよね
科学は発展すればするほどある時期から好奇心はすボムということをまあ証明したわけ
ですね
以上ですこれが理科離れの原因です
って言ったら終わりですよ猫なんですねなんとかしないといけないでしょさあどうし
ますかこのままではダメですよね
解決策はもうこの式みたら一発です1つしかありません
これです
理解の限界をあげてください
しっかり勉強してくださいということでしっかり勉強して知識を得てください理解の
限界があるとこの関数上がってきますそうすると鬼神関数も理想的なものに近づいて
くるわけですね
元も子もない話ですけどそういうことです
あのねよく寝好奇心持って何かやれよーってよく言いますよねー
好奇心なんで急に湧いてきません
黒人がそんなに簡単には君だったら好奇心だらけになります好奇心というのはやはり
知識があって理解があって勉強していないと好奇心でわかないんですね
この後先のことを逆に考えてはいけませんその順番を守らないといけないわけだか科学
が発展すればするほどしっかり勉強してください
そういうことになります
ここでちょっと私の話にします私は元素感があります
だからこそ持てる好奇心というものがあるわけですね
だからこそやりたいなと思う好奇心があるわけです
その事例を話します
先ほど言いましたように錬金術というのはできないと言いました
でも私なりの好奇心からもしかしたらできるんじゃないかなあなんてことを思えるよう
になってきたんですね
もう1回秋季業の一部を出してますターンその横に b 4ソっていう幻想があります
ね
あんまり馴染みないかもしれませんけどこれならなじみありますかね
ホウ酸団子とかってご存じですね中野ゴキブリを駆逐するのに使われるみたいですけど
も
方沿ってねここに書いてるみたいにスペが3本あって平面の形してるんですね
ああああああ
だからまあ一般的にはまぁこの形で表すということです
でもしもこの放送無理やり形を変えてやったら
放送が放送でなくなるんじゃないかなって思うようになったんですね
でもそれは無理なんですよホースはこうだこんな形してるから放送なんですねもし
無理やり帰れたらどうなるかな要するにこれをぐっとこう歪めてやるわけですね
こんな感じです
でもね試薬やさん入ってホウ素化合物買うでしょそうするとこの平面の者しか売って
くれませんねどうするのかなと思って学生さんと一生懸命共同で何年かかけてやっと
こういう歪んだホース作ることができたんですね
でこれをある反応に持っていったところ
これ数字が大きいほうがいいんですけどもすごくこの反応を推し進めるということが
分かりました
実はこの反応というのは多くの場合貴金属でないとなかなかうまくいかない反応なん
ですね
それがなんと保護三段五ちょこちょこっと変えたようなこんなもので行けるようになっ
たんですね
これどうですか歩い日錬金術だと思いませんちょっと騙してるみたいですけどもでも
これ概念を変えたある意味そういうことです
でいたいのは何かというと
たった100種類のものしかもこのようなて彼にはないわけですね新しいものを作れ
ないというけれどもやっぱり知識があって好奇心があればなんとかちょっとやり方は s
ですけれども
ある意味新元素を生み出すようなことだってできるんだよとそういう事例としてお話し
ましたですから何もないところ
そんな事を思いませんよねやはりそういう感覚と知識があるからこそ好奇心が湧いて
くるそういうものだという風に考えてほしいという風
もう1回美しい姿できました2回目ですね
どうですか一番はじめに見たときとだいぶ感じ変わって見えませんか
ちょっと私元素間の話をしたのでちょっとそんなことを考えてみたいなという新しい
感覚でこの花を今少し見れるようになってるかな
なっていただいた嬉しいなぁなんて思います私は元素間でこれを見るのでこの赤い花
どうやってこの赤色どんな分子で赤を出しているのかこの黄色はどうかな
どんな分しかなそんなこと思います
あるいはこの花が成長していくときにどんな元素とどんなですかどんな反応してできる
んだろうか
あるいは枯れていくときにどういう風な作用で幻想が枯れていくんだろうかそんなこと
思っているんですね
どうですか元素感があると楽しそうでしょ
でも私が本当に言いたいのは皆さんに元素感を持ってくださいねということを
実は言いたいんではないんですね
皆さんは私にはない知識を絶対持っています
そしてもっと言うと全員が絶対違う知識を持っているわけですね
その知識の理解の限界をグッと上げませんか
そうすると新しい好奇心とが絶対出てくると思うんですね
それは私には絶対出ないような好奇心ですそれ百人いれば百に違う好奇心が出てきます
その好奇心でこの花みてください
みんな月違う好奇心で見たらものすごく対応にこの花を見ることができると思いません
か
私は元素間でこの花を見ます皆さんはどんな感覚でこの花を見るでしょうか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]